it has been a concern since the
beginning of the pandemic and it still
persists medical professionals saying
kids are missing routine vaccinations
that are crucial for their health like
the flu shot this despite the fact there
are programs in place to support
families who can't afford them kirsten
joyce has more
cerise morata's five-year-old son joseph
came home from kindergarten in the fall
of 2009 not feeling well he was a
healthy happy kid and
he got sick they rushed him to urgent
care he was then transported to the
hospital where doctors diagnosed him
with the flu the nice day of his
hospital today
unfortunately his blood pressure
plummeted he went back to the icu
he suffered some complications that
ultimately ended up taking his life just
because we're in the middle of a
pandemic these other illnesses and
infections have not gone away zakipa
henderson is the senior vp for march of
dimes it's launched a national campaign
to address disparities in routine
childhood immunizations that vary based
on race ethnicity poverty and insurance
coverage according to data from cdc
since november of 2020 40 of kids have
missed their routine vaccinations due to
the pandemic and as of may 2021 overall
orders for children vaccines to the
uninsured and underinsured were down by
11.7 million doses as compared to 2019.
medical professionals say missing
routine vaccinations puts families at
risk for preventable infections like
measles mumps rubella and complications
from the flu that can lead to death
since her son's passing cerise has spent
12 years working to raise awareness
about vaccines with the national
non-profit vaccinate your family we
encourage other parents other folks to
seek out credible information on
vaccines she wants to save other
families from the loss hers suffered
kirstjen joyce live local now